[Music]
Charleston has a complex history because
of its ties with the Atlantic slave
trade in recent years historic sites
have reevaluated how they tell the city
story CBS this morning Saturday co-host
Michelle Miller shows us the changes
Charleston's history certainly
complicated for the last seven years
Charleston has been the top US city for
travel and leisure readers a city known
for its cobblestone streets in elegant
homes but just 200 years ago the city
was also the capital of the u.s. slave
trade nearly 40% of all enslaved
Africans brought here came through the
city's port a harsh reality than many in
Charleston used to gloss over I think
it's crucial that we tell the entire
story now tour guides like John Laverne
make it the most important point to
visitors because a lot of people what
they know about Charleston is what
they've seen on TV you've got to discuss
every horrific part of the entire
institution of slavery but norm powers
heads up the Center for the Study of
slavery in Charleston at the College of
Charleston it's very important to be
frank and honest and forthright about
the brutality of the system of slavery I
mean there is there's no getting around
this was an aspect of daily life and
that's exactly what historians at
Charleston's Nathaniel Russell House are
trying to do every house that was built
before 1865 in Charleston was built on
the backs of enslaved men women and
children Seren Northup is the director
of museums for the Historic Charleston
foundation it's so important that
visitors to these sites understand that
enslaved people were people they had
agency they had skills they had hopes
and dreams and relationships and
families and while some say Charleston
is making progress others believe the
work is just beginning the disparities
that exist between african-americans and
whites in this community they are still
very glaring otha meadows president and
CEO of the Charleston Triton Urban
League says those inequalities could
turn black voters and
Charleston away from the polls in 2020
how many folk in the african-american
community actually go out and exercise
their right to vote I think a lot of
African Americans don't feel that
elected officials are making policy and
decisions in their best interests they
are disenfranchised the city of
Charleston has been working to bridge
the gap in 2018 the City Council
formally passed a resolution to
apologise for his role in slavery by a
vote of 7 to 5 it was a win some
celebrated as a sign of how far
Charleston has come for others like
councilman William Dudley Gregory the
close margin represented how far
Charleston still has to go we as a
modern day council at a minimum should
recognize the errors of the ways of our
predecessors an attempt to make things
whole while we can recognition will that
work continues at the site where so many
enslaved Africans actually entered the
u.s. constructions underway on the
International African American Museum
which will be dedicated to telling the
stories of Africans is set to be open
next year this is so important because
history is sometimes painful and a lot
of times you know people tried to act
like that didn't happen but I like what
Lauren or Thor said enslaved people were
people with hopes and dreams absolutely
sometimes you recognize the errors of
our way and recognize that yes that
happened you forget it and how can you
gloss over it that's why it's important
that you did this story Thank You
Michelle
we'll be right back